foreign
excellencies distinguished guests
I'm fully aware of the fact that between
you
and a wonderful main course in cutting
the cake is only one obstacle and that's
me
and therefore I'll be brief
on the 1st of January this year I was in
Zagreb
not to celebrate New Year but to
celebrate gracious accession to the
Eurozone
and the joy I saw the enthusiasm The
Pride on that very day was impressive
was heartwarming touching
and it once again told me that the euro
is so much more than cash in our pockets
the Euro defines in many ways what we
are as a union
a union between national identity and
the European destiny
the euro is the symbol of the ideals we
share
and the stability we promote
20 member states
350 million people
one single currency
and we will need this strength
because when we talk about climate
change
digitalization
and our massive need for investment
the answer is not just wind turbine
semiconductors and speed
the answer is also a strong and a
reliable currency
for our European green deal
Europe's growth strategy
I am very grateful
to have the ECB as a trusted partner
Europe not only leads the global
transition
to climate neutrality by 2050.
but the Euro has become the currency of
choice
for sustainable Finance
we have started issuing green bonds
worth 250 billion euros
as part of next Generation EU
this makes us the largest issue of green
Bonds in the world
now we must stay the course ensure that
Europe delivers
on its Collective commitment to a
sustainable future
and the ECB is of course playing its
part from assessing Financial risks
related to climate change
to Greening monetary policy operations
and helping to scale up green Finance
a second thought of course is about
digitalization
our economies are rapidly going digital
and yes we are eager
to explore the full potential of AI
and we want to know about all the other
groundbreaking Technologies for our
industry and services
so together with the ECB we are working
on a digital version of the euro
to complement our trusted banknotes and
coins
we should never forget
who it is meant to serve and that is our
citizens
it is a trust of our citizens and
businesses
that the digital Euro needs to earn
in this spirit
the commission will shortly put forward
a proposal
for a legal framework
for Europe's digital currency
and finally as has been said we have
unfinished work in the economic and
monetary Union that underpins the euro
our banking Union needs to be completed
we also urgently need to progress on the
capital markets Union
there is no other way to unleash the
huge Investments necessary for the green
and the digital transition
and our economic governance framework
needs to tackle
the current reality of high public debt
and huge investment needs
I know
the ECB is a powerful advocate
of further progress in strengthening our
economic and our monetary Union
the commission has
foresold it proposals on the field on
the table and all these fields now
we must work together
to make those proposals a reality
so
with these thoughts
and these announcements
happy birthday dear ECB
25 years of ECB are not only 25 years of
prosperity and stability
but also a great example of European
strength
that we can develop if we act as one
foreign
[Applause]